I'm gonna give you just a brief
introduction to a Google security model
I'll talk to you a little bit about some
of the security products that we've got
we've got in the works and and I'll also
talk about compliance which we'll get
into a little bit about what we were
talking earlier about the MPAA so very
quickly when we when I'm talking about
Google Cloud I'm talking about our
compute storage and application services
and I actually there's a few more things
that we've added to this slide since
since I created this deck but for those
of you that the cloud is a new thing we
do have our compute engine and App
Engine which are which provide the
compute services we have a variety of
storage technologies probably Google's
cloud storage and also our participant
disk capabilities are probably most
interesting to this audience and then we
have services like bigquery which you
guys can have a lot of fun with if you
need to analyze tons and tons of
unstructured data let me talk a little
bit about our security model and just I
just so everybody knows this was slight
here we did a we did a project about a
year and a half ago with an author for
from Wired magazine and we actually
there's a really great article that
Wired wrote about our data centers and
we had we had the pleasure of bringing
in really great photographer came and we
took him through the data centers and
stuff and got a bunch of beautiful
pictures but and so my presentation is
sprinkled with these with these
beautiful pictures but their to do to
two things one is they're really nice so
it makes it makes me look better but the
other thing is is that hopefully it'll
give you a sense of a little bit of the
scale that we're talking about when we
talk about Google so when you're
thinking about when you're thinking
about not not even just cloud vendors
but when you're thinking about you know
service providers in general kind of the
the types of things you know a CIO or a
CSO might take into consideration is you
know what the what's the technology and
what is what is the technology that's
available to me is it going to make what
I need to do easier is it easy to access
is easy to take advantage of is a
keeping pace or
is it you know ahead of the curve and so
you know that's a real big consideration
of like why would I go to a service
Rider do they provide me a better
technology and in some instances the
answer is yes in some instances the
answer is no and then you know the other
quite frankly the other reason the key
reason that anybody would want to take
advantage of a public cloud is it's just
a scale the scale of operation and you
know can I work with a vendor that can
provide me the scale that I need to do
the do the jobs that I want to that I
want to do and can they provide me that
scale at you know something that's
competitive with with myself doing it
doing it myself and then also you know
how is that vendor are they agile can
they keep up with things I mean from a
security point of view or they keep me
up with the threat environment and they
doing the right types of things and are
they doing this in a manner that I don't
have to worry about it and can they do
it faster than my staff and so these are
all kinds of considerations that that
we've encountered as we've talked to
customers across a wide variety of
industries but these seem to be the
things that that come to front of mind
as people are thinking about taking
advantage of Google's cloud platform so
the good news is to kind of answer those
questions is is that the environment
that the cloud platform that we're
making available to our customers
is the platform that we use ourselves
and we use this platform to run our
global search and advertising business
our our Google Apps business runs on
this our YouTube business runs on this
this is the infrastructure that we are
we are servicing our hundreds of
millions of users across the globe and
so so this is the real deal it's not
something special we've built just to
just to build a cloud platform and
there's some really interesting
characteristics about about it for us
security is a base principle of what we
think about because the because we do
use this environment to run our own
business we we want to protect that
business the the search and advertising
business is a pretty good business for
Google and so we have security as a
foundational thought in terms of
building our infrastructure and services
on top of that infrastructure and so
some some of the things that are that
are
kind of interesting about it is is that
we build our own servers in our own
networking equipment and in fact we're
one of the top five server manufacturers
on the globe but those servers that we
build are exclusively for our own use
and it's the interesting thing about it
is is we've got largely a homogeneous
fleet and you might think oh well you
know why is that important well the
thing that's really interesting there is
that that enables us to maintain the
fleet in a couple of dimensions one is
we it's very clear to us what the
hardware and software profile looks like
on that fleet because it's it's the same
across the whole fleet and the other
thing is is that as a result of that
we're able to react react to things like
patch management and dealing with
vulnerabilities much much quicker than
we would if our tens of thousands of
servers were all different versions of
software and different Hardware profiles
and things like that so it's a it's a
simplicity idea which enables us to do
things at very large scale we have
dozens of data center spread around the
globe that enable us to deliver under
uninterrupted services to all of our
customers we protect data that we
protect our data at rest we protect data
in transit we use encryption
technologies to help us take care of
that one of the other things that's very
interesting about Google as a as a
service provider or as just a commercial
entity is that we're very I Google is
very interesting in a very disciplined
in our software development process but
we and and through that we're able to do
we we do some things as best practices
which hate which help us deliver more
secure services and things things that
we do there is for example all services
that we build get security and privacy
design reviews ahead of any code being
written all code that's written by a
Google engineer is at least reviewed by
a peer before it's checked into our
source code repository and we also have
separation between our development
operation and our in our actual
operations of the services and in fact
one of them interesting another kind of
fun fact is that software services that
we deliver into production come through
a certified build system and we actually
validate that
so you can actually go into our
production service and patch anything
unless it goes through our build
services and is certified so there's no
way for a development engineer sitting
somewhere in Google to actually insert
code into our production systems that's
not supposed to be there we also take
advantage of external security
verifications and validations we'll run
the whole gamut of we use commercial
scanners to scan our services looking
for vulnerabilities and we also will go
we'll take a step back and we will bring
in independent security verifiers to
actually go through source code reviews
with us and help us look at things that
we really want it truly hardened and we
want an unbiased we want to take an
unbiased look at as Dave was saying
earlier we have over 500 personnel that
are specifically involved in security
and privacy at Google and many of these
people are actually experts in their
field and they they continue to do
security research and publish they
continue to blog and comment on the
security industry and they they do tons
of presentations a variety of
conferences everything from black hat to
RSA and everything in between
we also we also have one thing that
we're really proud of and this is
something that we started in the
industry is we have our vulnerability
rewards program where we actually pay
bounties to security researchers to find
problems in our software and for example
this particular program found over 700
vulnerabilities our bugs in the in the
Chrome browser over the over the life
cycle of its development and the program
has paid out over two million dollars to
date to security researchers and
oftentimes the bounties are ten twenty
thousand dollars at a pop so you can
imagine some some grad student working
on his PhD is able to live for a year
off finding uh finding a bug at Google I
fortunately don't eat that much ramen
anymore so I'm a little bit more
expensive but some of them really enjoy
it and the other thing that we do is we
give them credit for it and so for those
researchers that find those things we we
make sure that the world knows
that they did us a favor which helps
them out as they're building up their
CVS and looking to move beyond academia
we have a global network to deliver our
services and our customers of the cloud
platform can also take advantage of this
one of the other things that that we're
particularly proud of is that we we
liked we believe that we we've done a
lot of we provided a lot of leadership
and security innovation across the
industry and doing things like ensuring
that all the email that comes out of
Gmail and comes into Gmail is protected
with transport layer security we've gone
to HTTPS on all of our services we we
did we were one of the first providers
to get the ISO 27001 certification on
our Google Apps services our SAS
offering for collaboration applications
and and some we have some other you know
things that we continue to do we
recently we we recently put out or a
couple years ago and we've pushed we've
we've done TLS on Gmail and we've heard
we recently published a safe email site
which has identified the service
providers who are not taking advantage
of TLS and the interesting side effect
of that is that some some service
providers who will go unnamed quickly
upgraded their services once once we
shined a little sunlight on that so let
me shift gears over here just just a
moment and let's if you're thinking
about if you know if you're thinking
about IT security or think about your
services you're thinking about using a
vendor you know what kinds of things are
you worried about so I'm gonna take a
couple moments here and just kind of
give you guys a taste of the threat
model of the environment that we're
thinking about and also what we've
learned from a lot of customers that
we've talked about and just in case
you're curious about this this is the
crew at our data center in Finland you
know they're getting out getting a
little sunshine here so I you know who
are you gonna worry about you know
here's here's here's the here's the
spectrum of folks that we worry about
Packers
we worried about you know
you know if we're customer worried about
the service provider we worry about our
own personnel and in the shoes of our
customers worried about they can worry
about themselves as well and we also
worry about governments and let's dig in
a little bit here so hackers so we we
have a lot of mechanisms we've put in
place as you can well imagine Google's a
very large target and we have persistent
attacks going on it's been going on for
years and the hacking communities had
very very little success in in being
successful against Google but the
interesting thing is because we do have
such a wide footprint we and we do see a
lot of traffic across the globe and
enables us to get smarter and smarter on
our countermeasures and we build those
things into our front-end services and
the things that face the Internet and we
learn about a lot of threats and our
customers get to take advantage of those
protections well what about us what
about what about Google as the service
provider I already described our
software development process to you we
also we also employ a lease privilege
model in terms of access to customer
data which there are VPS in the company
that are responsible for granting that
access and we also perform background
checks on our employees and you know we
do have we we have a security and
privacy focus culture we have public
information on our Investor site that
explains the the employee code of
conduct which employees agree to when
they started they start employment with
us and we we refresh the privacy and
security information training to our
employees on an annual basis and we do
this top to bottom every employee in the
company the other things that that are
hallmarks of you know contrary to what
you might read in the press and stuff is
that as a customer of Google it's very
clear that you own your data and you are
the control over that data Google
operates in a role of a data processor
and follows your instructions we're not
sharing this information with
anybody else we're not using it for our
other businesses we're using it we use
your data to provide the service to you
in the manner that you want it as I said
we have a we we have strict internal
policies that follow up on the privacy
and security training and you know I'll
be really honest we've fired people for
violating that we've shown them the door
very quickly we take it very seriously
and we also we also you know we verify
what we say we verify our policies we we
track and audit our employees activities
to make sure that we're doing what we
say we do as a customer we provide you
control over your own data and so well
this is yeah this is an example of one
of our user interfaces it's actually a
little bit dated but what I'm trying to
demonstrate to you here is that this is
how we give the control of the customer
they control the access they control who
uses that they control which services
are being used and so all of that
control is placed in the hands of the
customers we do have a customer support
organization that will help you out if
you run into trouble with that but you
are using these resources and
controlling them yourselves let's let's
talk about governments and this you know
this becomes very interesting in that I
don't know if it really applies as much
to the median entertainment industry as
it does some of the other industries but
we always have customers that are
concerned about about governments
getting access to data that's stored in
our cloud and so a couple things about
that one is you may or may not be aware
but Google was the first to publish what
we call a government transparency report
and so we are we are publishing
information about all the information
requests we get from the US federal
government and other governments around
the world we in in our Terms of Service
or in our agreements with the customers
our customers are responsible for
dealing with government requests and and
and it's and it's our policy to make
sure that whoever is making that request
really understands that really
interfaces with the customer and in the
situations where that doesn't happen in
we can't do that unless we're compelled
by law it's also our policy to make sure
that the customer is aware that that
activity is going on and and we've we
push we push we push back on that to
make sure that it's that it's very
appropriately legal when those types of
things do happen
we're also Safe Harbor certified and
what that means is that that enables us
to comply with European privacy law and
that's we can we can present that to our
European customers so that they
understand that and gives us you know
legal legal standing and you don't have
to just take take our word for it this
is last year's scorecard presented by
the Electronic Frontier Foundation they
do an annual survey that they call who's
got your back where they rate the
various vendors in terms of how they're
dealing with handling the privacy of
their customers information and as you
can see in the middle of slide there we
scored very well with them the other
thing that's really interesting about
this is that we've we've improved over
time we haven't always gotten the
highest mark but the other thing that's
really nice about this is that the
Electronic Frontier Foundation does this
on an annual basis but they also adapt
it to the changing environment and so
they they're constantly pushing on what
they're measuring everybody on so it's
not just a kind of a static thing you
have to pay attention to what they're
what they're what they're paying
attention to and we tried to closely
okay let me let me get in let's let's
let's talk about compliance
so not specific to media and
entertainment we do run a formal
compliance program for a for cloud
platform and what we're trying to do
there is we are trying to in industry
specific terms convey to our customers
across the broad spectrum of industries
that we're complying with security and
privacy standards in those different
industries and and to that effect we
actually use third-party auditors to
attest to most of - most of these things
where it's appropriate and so just from
a from a an IT service provider point of
view the
ss a 16 and the ISO 27001 are two very
important standards there which we bring
in we have our third-party auditor which
is Ernst & Young certified point they
come in and do these audits for us on an
annual basis and we can provide
materials that back that up and show the
evidence to our customers that we're
doing that and so this is this has
served us very well in some other
industry verticals ISO 27001 is a pretty
rigorous security and privacy standard
focus mostly on IT security and there's
12 control areas there and and we meet
all of those control areas and can make
this certificate available to customers
based upon that we built upon that and
we're able to service the healthcare
industry by by complying with HIPAA and
we comply with HIPAA and we'll meet the
contractual requirements by providing a
business associates agreement to covered
entities in the healthcare space I know
that sounds like a lot of gobbly [ __ ]
but what that means is is that if you're
if you are building a healthcare
application which has patient data in it
that data is covered by the HIPAA laws
and we can provide an environment that
enables customers to deliver those type
of applications but be sure that the
service provider us is making sure that
that data stays safe and private and
we're backing that up in the contract we
and in a very similar vein we support
PCI DSS which is the payment card
industry data security standard we've
certified the whole platform against
version 2 and the reason it's version 2
is at the time we started the audit on
that version 3 hadn't been ratified by
the payment card industry yet they did
that work and we actually have just
completed our 3.0 certification and
we're signing certificates right now so
we're very shortly in fact you're the
first people that are hearing this right
now because I got the email this morning
but we'll be making some noise about
that but so for for those Reap for those
folks in the retail industry and the
people in the banking in
the street that are dealing with payment
card data we provide this assurance that
that will safeguard that information as
well and they can use that to build up
their compliance story with their
auditors and with with their customers
that they need to do that with very
quickly FISMA FedRAMP these are US
federal government standards for
government to be able to take advantage
of information services we've done FISMA
where appropriate FedRAMP has replaced
that and it's currently in process we
have a goal of getting that done by the
end of the year so we can tap into those
US federal government customers that
require that and the vendors that
support them as well and then I have
this I have this dream out here that I
call the MPAA which is really relevant
to this crowd and so I'll just give you
the story on this is that we're paying
attention to it we looked at the the
first version of the standard we're like
okay this isn't a really a you know this
is this is pretty straightforward we
think we can meet or exceed this the
requirements in here but as we start to
get to know people in the industry and
stuff and we learned a little bit more
we kind of everybody was kind of like
well okay that's not really that doesn't
do anything for us and not only did we
hear that but I think the MPAA heard
that as well and so they've gone off and
I think there's several people in this
room that have been involved in that and
we've talked to some people the major
studios that have been involved with
that as well and they're they're
retooling that and they're retooling
that to think more about cloud services
and some and some more complex things
that could be done and so we're
anxiously awaiting them to publish that
standard so that we can we can
communicate you know an assessment
against that to everybody so that's an
activity that we have going on and
hopefully that'll be something it's
probably not to be all end all but
hopefully that'll be something that
helps you know you guys to be able to
take advantage of our platform and in
our competitors platforms to be quite
frank you know hopefully that'll that'll
give an inch away aside from that we're
also trying to figure out and trying to
navigate the process
of working with the studios and really
trying to listen and understand what the
studios want to understand what we can
do to demonstrate to them that we're
meeting or exceeding their expectations
in terms of protecting their data and
enabling their vendors to take advantage
of our services and protect their data
as well and so you know we're hoping I
mean the not-too-distant future that
we'll be able to tell a richer story
there so so that there can be broader
use of our platform in your industry
very quickly one of the other things
that we're doing we talked about having
these over 500 folks that work on
security at Google we've built up a
pretty rich toolset inside inside of our
security organization that we use on our
own products and one of the things that
I'm I'm in the process of doing is I'm
in the process of commercializing some
of these products and this is an example
of the first one that that's coming out
this is called cloud security scanner
what this does is this is a tool that
works in conjunction with applications
that are developed on Google App Engine
and it basically will scan that for
common web development vulnerabilities
cross-site scripting errors Dom problems
and this is a tool we use on our own and
all products that we launch to the web
have to pass through this tool or they
they can't get launched and so what
we've done is we've made this available
to our customers it's currently in beta
it's available in the developers console
and you can run it against your own
applications and you get feedback on it
you can fix the bugs and part of what
we're trying to do here is make our
platform a really logical place to
deliver safe and secure applications and
let you guys take advantage of like
years of expertise we happen in dealing
with that so lastly what I'm going to
want to convey here is let us worry
about the security so that you guys can
innovate and take advantage of that and
and take off and really focus on what
you want to do focus on creative things
focus on innovative software innovative
applications and let us help you with
the security side of things